cuando hablamos de dinero la cantidad no
es lo que interesa no únicamente
interesa eso también interesa cuando
recibirás el dinero y cuando tendrás que
darlo para pensar más en esto vamos a
asumir que vivimos en un mundo en el que
si tú pones dinero en el banco entonces
se te garantiza obtener el 10% en
interés así que 10% en interés libre de
libre de riesgo este es un interés alto
dado los estándares históricos pero
ahora nuestro ejemplo más sencillo
asumamos entonces que siempre podemos
obtener 10% en interés libre de riesgo
en el banco y bueno ahora dado eso yo
podría yo pondré escenarios aquí tú tú
puedes elegir cuál quieres entonces en
el número 1 aquí hoy yo podría darte 100
pesos ahora mismo ahora mismo entonces
ese es es la opción número uno o en un
año te podría dar 109 pesos en lugar de
100 inmediatos tú esperarías un año y yo
te doy 109 pesos o en dos años es la
opción número 3 estaría dispuesto a
darte ciento 120 pesos 120 pesos
entonces tú tienes opciones y alguien
llega a la calle y salta enfrente de ti
y te dice ok mía yo te puedo dar hoy hoy
mismo 100 pesos y tú así lo eliges o 109
en un año o 120 en dos años entonces tú
tú en el fondo sabes que tú puedes
obtener el 10% interés libre de riesgo y
dado a que no tienes necesidad ahora am
inmediata por dinero hace un mes que
guardarás ese dinero así que bueno no
tienes por el momento ninguna deuda cuál
de estas opciones es la más deseada cuál
por cuál te irías tú si solamente te
preocupa la cantidad entonces bueno
pesos 220 pesos y dices que te vas por
ese obviamente pero quizás también bueno
pienses estos 120 van a tardar en llegar
a mis manos así que si te estarías
perdiendo de la oportunidad de obtener
el 10% libre de riesgos si obtienes el
dinero antes entonces sí
nos vamos a comparar vamos a comparar
directamente si eliges la opción número
entonces obtienes 100 pesos y los pones
en el banco cuánto crecerá eso basándote
en el 10% libre de riesgo cuánto va a
crecer
bueno pues veamos después de un año 10%
de 100 pesos son 10 pesos entonces
obtendremos 10 pesos en interés así que
después de un año tú ahorrarás tus
ahorros sumarán 110 pesos así que
haciendo esto simplemente podemos ver
que 100 pesos dados ahora los pones en
el banco con 10% libre y obtendrás 110
pesos de aquí a un año lo cual es mucho
mejor que los 109 pesos entonces dada
esta opción
obviamente vas a preferir los la opción
número 1 porque de esta manera tú
obtendrás un peso más y bueno no te urge
y un peso más es un peso más que pasará
de aquí a dos años bueno pues vamos a
tomar los 100 pesos después de un año
son 110 y 10% de 110 son 11 pesos eso es
lo que se sumará a 11 pesos se
convertirán en 121 pesos
aquí a un año 121 pesos de aquí a un año
una vez más conviene más la opción
número 1 invirtiendo esos 100 pesos en
el banco con el 10% libre al año se
convertirán en 121 pesos lo cual es
mejor que la situación donde alguien te
garantiza 120 pesos en dos años una vez
más tú tienes un peso un peso más un
peso más de ganancia y bueno esta idea
en la que no solamente la cantidad
importa sino que también importa cuando
te lo están dando a esta idea se le
llama valor tiempo del dinero valor
tiempo del dinero otra manera de
pensarlo sería bueno piensa en el valor
de este dinero pasando un tiempo dado
una tasa de interés y cuando haces eso
tú puedes comparar ese dinero a
cantidades iguales de dinero en un
tiempo futuro y otra manera también de
pensar en valor tiempo otro concepto
relacionado con con valor tiempo de
dinero es la idea de valor actual valor
actual
y quizás luego hable sobre el valor
actual y valor futuro así que lo voy a
poner aquí valor actual y valor futuro
entonces lo escribo y bueno ya dada esta
asunción este 10% si alguien llegara a
preguntarle a preguntarte bueno cuál es
el valor actual de 121 pesos a dos años
en el futuro lo que esencialmente te
está preguntando es bueno mira lo voy a
escribir aquí cuál es el valor actual
valor actual y ve a abreviar valor
actual cuál es el valor actual de 121
pesos a dos años en el futuro o qué
cantidad de dinero tuviste que poner en
el banco con interés libre de riesgo en
los dos años para obtener 121 pesos y ya
lo sabemos si ponemos 100 pesos en el
banco para dos años en 10% libre
obtendríamos 121 pesos entonces el valor
actual de 121 pesos son los 100 pesos
así que esto es igual igual a 100 pesos
y otra manera de pensar en el valor
actual y en el valor futuro si alguien
te fuera a preguntar bueno cuál es el
valor futuro de esos 100 pesos en un año
año en el valor futuro bueno pues pues
si tú sí tú obtiene el 10% del banco el
cual está garantizado este entonces su
valor futuro son 110 pesos después de
dos años el valor futuro es de 121 pesos
y con todo esto en mente vamos a poner
esto un poco más interesante digamos que
tengo vamos a vamos a asumir esto todo
el tiempo estos este 10% porque hace los
cálculos sencillos y digamos que alguien
está dispuesto a darnos 65 pesos en un
año así que alguien nos va a dar 65
pesos en un año un año y nos preguntamos
lo siguiente lo hemos estado haciendo
todo este tiempo cuál es el valor actual
de esto y recuerda el valor actual de el
valor actual no se está preguntando cuál
es la cantidad de dinero que si lo pongo
en el banco con este 10% libre será
equivalente a los 65 pesos entonces el
equivalente a esto de aquí tú dirías
pues mira cualquiera que sea esa
cantidad
de dinero llamémosle x entonces x x si
lo estoy aumentando por el 10% entonces
quedaría de esta manera x más 10 por x
10 por ciento por x deberá ser igual a
65 pesos ajá si yo tomo la cantidad
obtengo 10% de esa cantidad y tendría
que ser 65 pesos entonces esto de aquí
es igual a 1 x x + 10 por ciento por x
es igual a 65 entonces lo voy a escribir
aquí abajo aquí tengo 1 x x + 10 por
ciento es 0.10 por x 65 sumando estos
dos es 1.10 por x 65 y para saber a qué
equivale x vamos a dividir ambos lados
por el 1.10 así que lo voy a poner aquí
entonces esto lo divido entre 1.10 y acá
también entre 1.10 ahora el cero este
además obviamente está demás pero
simplemente estamos hablando de 10%
exacto así que esto se va y x igual a 65
entre 1.1 así que sacó la calculadora
para saber cuánto es eso
entonces 65 65 entre 1.1 es 59 puntos 09
hablamos de 59 pesos con 9 centavos
exactamente entonces x es igual a 59
pesos con 9 centavos que es el valor
actual de 65 pesos en un año también si
quieres saber el valor futuro de 59
pesos con 9 centavos en un año asumiendo
este 10% obtendrás los 65 pesos